heureusement pour vous vous ne sentez
pas l'odeur nauséabonde qui règne ici à
conflans sainte honorine
une odeur du au poisson mort trois
tonnes de poissons décédées ont été
recueillis par bateau ce week-end entre
hr et le barrage d'andrésy la récolte
continue
plusieurs tonnes de poissons asphyxié
ans guy flottante ou perche mortes ont
été repêchés dans les eaux de la senne
suite à l' incendie de la station
d'épuration d'achères les résidents des
péniches constate les dégâts
depuis mercredi que ça dure comme ça
mercredi soir avec un petit bateau qui à
côté de moi on était monté dans l'île il
ya des deux agents du siaap qui sont
venus et ils ont vu il y avait des
milliers de poissons qui est à la
surface en train de respirer qui
essayait de se trouver
même les anguilles sortait de l'eau pour
monter sur la berge pour pouvoir
échapper à la pollution au décompte même
pu laver le bateau peut rien faire à
part aux et des plantes rien du tout ils
ras-le-bol lincendie du site qui traite
60% des eaux usées de l'agglomération
parisienne et le troisième depuis
février 2018
une réunion d'information s'est déroulée
à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye
nous avons évoqué différentes questions
notamment celle des mesures et de l'eau
et de l'air aucune toxicité pour l'air
et dans l'eau
aucune des données n'est maintenant
dépasser et à nous
aucune n'est dangereuse une catastrophe
naturelle déplorable pour la
biodiversité de la scène selon les
associations ont géré directement les 6
premiers kilomètres qui sont assorties
déroger de la station d'épuration et on
considère que 90 % de mortalité sur ces
6 km ces poissons là ils ont aussi donc
bah ils servent de sources alimentaires
dont toute une chaîne alimentaire qui va
concerner d'autres espèces animales que
des poissons la cciab s'engage à
continuer d'enlever les poissons morts
ainsi carré empoissonné la scène nous
allons bien sûr travailler de concert
avec la drieu et les fédérations de
pêche de manière à pouvoir reconstituer
ses frayères au plus vite de manière à
ce que je dirais 7 mortels piscicole ne
soit plus qu'un épisode dramatique
derrière nous une crainte persiste la
température de la scène et de 25 degrés
avec un faible débit
200 mètres cubes seconde ce qui ne
favorise pas une bonne à réoxygénation
de l'eau une nouvelle réunion est prévue
afin de faire le point sur l'évolution
de la situation
lundi 15 juillet à la sous-préfecture de
saint-germain-en-laye